so the background here by the way Shawn
is I was on James's show three weeks ago
and actually air today yes I've been
getting people reached out reaching out
to me James James is an oddball I like
him he's been around and done all types
of interesting stuff he's had books he's
got paid newsletters he's I don't know
what how you describe yourself but
you're just kind of all over the place
and you've done all types of stuff and
you have a really interesting life and
we thought we'd get up we thought we'd
get him on here and we could talk about
anything but uh do you know about James
Sean I know about you yeah I know about
him I've read about your stuff I was
like this guy's the and then I read
I read something that was like I think
you were talking about bit coin and
crypto at the time and I was like wait a
minute is this just a guy who just just
sells the latest thing like oh here's
the new thing cool I'll seal that and I
was like okay I don't how I feel about
this and then I've read some of your
stories where you talk about how you
made money and lost it all over and over
and over again and I was like this guy
is very interesting you reminded me of
like if Tim Ferriss you know smoked a
bunch of weed and was on the Internet I
don't know like is this like some some
variation of really interesting guy who
potent you know who's built his brand on
the internet you know you always had
like something unexpected like it wasn't
the formulaic thing like even the fact
that you own a comedy club is like you
always have sort of unexpected things
that's what I have sort of come to like
about you but you know that's my
admittedly very loose knowledge about
about you do you want to give some
background yeah I mean it's kind of like
what you were both sort of referring to
have I've had for better or for worse a
lot of different interests which I
turned into a lot of different careers
and I say for better or for worse
because a lot of times I would have an
interest I'd built a business I'd sell
it I'd make money and then for some
reason I would just I don't know I would
totally the bed and lose everything
and I'm not talking about like oh I sold
something for a billion and I ended up
with ten million this is horrible no I
would sell something for millions and
then end up with 0 or less than zero in
my bank account
really just zero actually I wish
sometimes it's better to be less than
zero than to be zero because if you like
are less than zero then that means
there's a deal you could work out with
somebody
like oh I owe you 10 million let's work
it out and you maybe give me some so I
could build then I don't know what it is
but like I think it was a young man in
the 90s named Donald Trump who said if
you owe if you owe two million to the
bank the bank owns you but if you owe
two billion to the bank you owe in the
bank and but but anyway I would often
end up at $0 and be depressed to the
point of like suicidal like I had kids
to feed I had myself to feed and it's
really true when you go from having
money and selling a business to broke
you find out who your real friends are
and for me almost every time it turned
out I had zero friends and so I had
nowhere to go and and no idea and
depressed and I didn't know how in some
cases put food on the table for my kids
after having millions and so I had to
learn very quickly over and over again
what are my interests what can I pursue
what's an idea how to be creative and
maybe a horrible environment and then
figure out how to monetize it so I was a
software guy I worked in the
entertainment industry I work for HBO I
started I combined those two things and
I started a company in the 90s making
websites for entertainment companies and
then I became a venture capitalist then
I started a hedge fund I wrote some
software to help me invest in that and
then I started writing books about that
so I became a writer
then I became a podcaster and then like
you were saying I started writing about
much more personal stuff and I think
everybody who knew me couldn't believe
it like it was almost like they had
never seen anything like this before
like why they people call me up like
James are you do you have cancer or are
you about to kill yourself are you about
to die like why are you confessing to
all these things these are horrible no
one's ever gonna do a deal with you
again or this is too embarrassing and
I you know and then I think since then
people have I don't want to say people
copied it people have their own versions
of writing about failure and and so on
but and then those because I writing
books based on those articles and it
turned out I had not only was like
building up even more as a writer and my
audience was bigger than ever previously
I'd written about finance now I was
writing about all this personal stuff my
audience became a hundred times bigger
and then I started getting more
investment opportunities
I started gay cast which became
successful
I started getting many more
opportunities because of I because
because essentially I paid with my
vulnerability for freedom and that
created a whole kind of career for me
and it wasn't intentional I just was
sick of writing about all the BS stuff I
kept seeing everyone else write about
and if you want to if you want to be
unique you kind of have to say what's
unique to you and what was it unique to
me was all the times I was scared to
death and and depressed and and had to
fight my way out of it so many things to
answer the question I have back
background a lot of things and also I
always like trying new things and
experimenting and I was everything I'm
passionately interested in I like I like
figuring out how to make money from it
and and getting good at it
and so if somebody's listening and
they're like ok cool you made millions
how did you go to zero so what what was
happening what how are you making money
and how are you taking it to zero were
you just making wild bets or well yeah
yeah but where you're like hit I imagine
you've had like three hits yeah I would
say it's more like five or six hits
again provider or for worse I needed all
five or six but the first one again I
was working at HBO and I made their
website and at at the time other
entertainment companies and other
companies they didn't even know what
this Internet web thing was this was in
1995 and companies like American Express
American at his world have an American
Express would call Arthur Andersen which
was their accounting firm and you know
Arthur Andersen famously went on a
business in a scandal six years later
but American Express called him Arthur
Andersen said can you make us a website
Arthur Andersen said sure well they're
going to charge
millions of dollars Arthur Anderson
would then call another software
consulting company and they would say
yeah will charge you a million dollars
the software company would call me
because nobody knew how to make a
website in 1994-1995 so I would say sure
I'll do it and then suddenly they pay me
and my brother-in-law 250,000 dollars to
make American Express calm so that was
one of our first websites and I would my
salary at HBO at the time was 40,000 a
year so my brother-in-law and I we made
HBO calm then we made websites for
everything from Warner Brothers Sony
Disney BMG all the record labels like we
did every gangster rap record label bad
boy loud records jive death row
Interscope we did the movies for the
matrix and many other movies but anyway
that was and were these build up sites
at that time like if you looked at that
website today what would it look like is
it like a Craigslist well you know what
that's a great question so no it doesn't
look like Craigslist I wish it did but
design Web Design back in those days so
I was a software guy my brother-in-law
was a design guy web design back in
those days was very heavy so there would
be like big heavy images and animations
using flash or the you know some Mac I
forget the company macro something and
they were there are very heavy designs
not that usable and but yeah I mean they
were okay they were admired back then so
the website for the matrix was a great
website which you know on archive.org
you could find or HBO's web site was a
great website but it wasn't as
functional as all websites are now
wasn't very easy to navigate and you
walk away with at the end of that about
15 million and then oh yeah
so cash not not like so a lot of people
then you know when public or sold and
they got paper and then they died in the
dot-com bust because the paper went to
zero the stocks went to zero so I had
enough sense and like the peak in 1999 I
cashed out and I had the cash in my
checking account like I didn't even want
to mean cash out were you getting like
stock in these come I mean yeah so so no
I sold the company to a company that was
rolling up
web web agencies and so we in a sense
that was how we went public like some
company that made
I don't know vacuum cleaners or whatever
decided to get into the internet
business in 1998 and acquired us and so
suddenly they were an Internet company
and the stock went from three to forty
eight and I cashed out with literally at
the peak with about a little over 15
million almost 16 million cash and and
here I was I was smart every step of the
way like I knew that the web design
development business industry was going
away because they were teaching web you
know how to make a website in junior
high school classes so I knew that was
going away I was smart I sold the
business I cashed out as fast as I could
and then I became everybody you suddenly
when you when you make money at one
thing suddenly you think you're a genius
and everything or at least this happened
to me and everybody would come to me and
say hey how can what what should we
invest in or you know this internet
thing you you you have like curly hair
and glasses you must know have all this
internet stuff you're you look like a
technology guy what should we invest in
so I started thinking oh I must be
really smart at this and literally I
poured all this cash back into internet
investments after I cashed out of the
internet and it really went and then I
also I bought like a huge apartment in
New York City and the one thing I was
doing that everybody thought I lost all
my money on but it wasn't I was I was
gambling every single day like I was
playing poker for 365 straight days I
played poker at least 8 to 10 hours a
day I was going to ask you if you're a
degenerate gambler because you kind of
have that I mean you sound like that
before you even told me you're a gambler
but but but that's just it poker was the
one thing I probably should have stuck
with like I was doing well at poker and
it was right before the poker boom took
off when I decided you know what I'm
just gonna focus on starting new
companies and internet investing and I
stopped playing poker like in you know
right at the end of 1999 I started a
venture capital firm and I just started
investing money which was your firm all
you
money so your firm no no we raised we
raised 200 million dollars like only
that was the other thing too I
didn't have any experience doing any of
this stuff I didn't know anything um I'm
trying to remember all investors uh CS
first boston deutsche bank like all
these major banks gave us money and then
another company invest corp which is a
major private equity firm gave us a
hundred million and and then i started
investing my own personal money
side-by-side with the fund and in other
investments and i started buying stocks
all the way down so how long was chosen
0 from 15 to 0 how long was that I was
losing about a million dollars a week in
the summer of 2000 and and I just didn't
know what I was doing and it wasn't even
that I didn't know how to invest I
didn't know there's so many other skills
to investing than knowing what companies
are good and what companies are bad like
I didn't understand risk I didn't
understand money management I didn't
understand you know how to I really
didn't understand anything that about
investing like I was an idiot and I went
to zero by right around mid 2001 I put
up my I was desperately putting up my
apartment for sale cuz maybe I would
have some money left I stopped paying my
mortgage and maybe I would have some
money left after putting this apartment
up for sale I lived two blocks three
blocks from a little building called the
World Trade Center and we were getting
an offer on September 11 and of course
many worse things happened that day than
me not getting an offer for my house but
9/11 happened and we couldn't sell then
because we were part of the crime scene
and you know just I went totally really
broken were you home I was at the World
Trade Center oh my god which I don't
really I don't really talk about because
a it sounds unbelievable but be it also
many worse things happen to people to
many more people than me that day
obviously but my business partner and I
were there was a Dean & Deluca and on
the first floor of the World Trade
Center we ate breakfast there every day
and then we would day trade the markets
and at that point I was starting to come
back a little bit from day trading and I
had written some software and and so on
and then we're walking to my home where
I had my office and we my partner turns
to me and says is the president coming
into town today because this I look up
and there's this plane that's just like
right overhead and then boom we watched
it go right into that like physically we
watched it not on TV but like physically
we saw it go right into the building and
everybody on the street instinctively
ducked and and your brain does weird
things so my I started thinking to
myself like my business partners name's
Dan
he said we're we're being attacked and
I'm like no no no that was that was just
an accident
like and no one's no one's it's too
early no one's in the building like my
brain was telling me this even though it
was a quarter to nine a.m. and you know
how do you remote control us whatever
was a 747 into the World Trade Center
but that's what my brain was telling me
so we run to the fire station and we
said we want to help and these guys
throw two firemen suits at us and say
get this on we're gonna go straight over
there and we start putting it on but
then they say wait a second are you guys
firemen and we're like no we just wanted
to give blood or whatever we could do
and they're like no no only firemen and
that fire station it was the Duane
Street bio station a hundred percent of
those people died who went to the World
Trade Center that morning and and then
from you know there's a bad day but that
kind of clinched me losing everything
also because I had been invested in the
stock market that morning and boom
everything kind of went to went to zero
after that and then I was just desperate
for like a year and a half couldn't sell
the place couldn't there were no jobs I
was an idiot nobody would I had no
friends anymore and you know I had to I
had to teach myself how to invest so I
wrote some software where I took every
piece of data about every single stock
since World War two and looked for
patterns you know when would I would
have
my software find statistically
significant patterns where trades were
good so I would try to model let's say
fear and greed in the markets and and
and it worked pretty well doesn't it
wouldn't I don't think that strategy
would work now but it worked then
because there weren't there wasn't that
many quantitative investors in the
markets then this was kind of the
beginnings of that and so I was very
successful with it and that kind of kept
me alive and that's how I bit by bit I
started learning about investing this
gave me time to actually learn the skill
and and talk to people who were experts
and professionals and and really learned
then I started writing about investing
and I started going on CNBC and I
started a hedge fund and I started I
wrote my first book about investing and
so gradually I built these two careers
one in the hedge fund business and the
other in writing about investing and
going on CNBC and then I built so I was
doing deals also then and making money
and then I built a website that combined
my interest in web development with
investing made like a social I called it
the myspace of Finance cuz myspace was
big then and I sold that site and that
was like my next big hit sold that for
ten million and you know and then a year
later I was broke again and that's but
things like that just kept happening
alright this episode is brought to you
by super side alright so here's the deal
I'm incredibly impatient like horribly
horribly impatient and if I get an idea
at midnight by 8 a.m. the next day I
want it done you know but that's really
hard because if something needs to be
designed where am I gonna find designer
at midnight to try to make this thing
keep bring it to life so you know I
don't am alone other startups even huge
companies neat design help fast and they
just don't have the internal resources
or expertise to get it done so how do
you get reliable design done without
dealing with expensive agencies and lots
of freelancers you use super site that's
our sponsor for this week just go to
super site calm slash MFM and tell them
what you want they have a team of
designers that can get it done fast you
know they are 20 times faster than
hiring a designer and 50% more
affordable than a traditional agency so
if you need high quality design done
fast try super side lots of fast gory
teams that are
are using them already check them out
supers Icom /m fm I'm using before I
love them check it out there's a lot
going on here
but it's used told to companies so far
well you've also sold your newsletter
business too right yeah so that was a
third company and I've also sold
companies that I was on either there's
many companies I've been an investor up
that have been sold by this point and
then some companies that I'm like a
co-founder of that I've that I've sold I
was like involved I've been involved
with everything from like I'm a mental
rehab facility that's sold for 41
million and then that was in 2004 I did
go broke after that and then was stock
picker of the stock site and then I was
in an early investor in buddy media yeah
which Peter Thiel invested in my class
where I was the CEO Mark Pincus who
started Zynga was an investor in it and
we all were the seed investors at a four
million dollar valuation that sold the
Salesforce for about seven or eight
hundred million I had a company today
that I was a investor and it just it
just kind of did or they just announced
a reverse merger they're going public so
hopefully that will do well but I've
been I've been investor in a lot of
companies that have done well cause like
because I finally figured out the most
important thing about investing that I
missed before and that since then my
private investing has done very well and
I don't really do public investing oh
what's that thing that one thing is that
I am the worst idiot in the world if if
you're in a room with me I'm the
stupidest person in that room and what I
mean by that is take buddy media as an
example I didn't have to do any work
once I invested because Peter Thiel was
my co investor so it's not like they're
gonna call me for advice they're gonna
call the people smarter than me and also
presumably the first investor in
facebook wouldn't know what he was doing
when investing in a facebook marketing
agency which is what buddy media was so
so I always if someone a lot smarter
than me says hey I'm investing in this
company I don't even have to do any more
work I just send the check because I
assume and I'm always correct when I
assume this he's done or she's done all
the due diligence all the hard work he's
got PhDs working for him that are a lot
smarter than me
if worse comes to worse he or she can
make phone calls and get this company
acquired which is what happens and I've
done very well with just that one
strategy that if someone a lot smarter
than me is investing at the same terms
as me that's important too then I'm
going to do well and it's almost like a
hundred it's not like a normal success
rate it's like a hundred percent success
rate when you do that and and the other
rule is if they ever call me for advice
then on my spreadsheet where I keep
track of these I assume their value is
zero and I never call them back because
if they've reached so far down the totem
pole where they have to call me for
advice that means they're screwed so and
this secret works like it's amazing how
well that one technique works and so
that allows me to invest in at companies
ranging from oil companies to tech to
law enforcement to the company today is
an erectile dysfunction drug I don't
that I don't know anything about biotech
like the yeah but as long as someone you
know if if someone calls me and says
look hey I've started the last three
erectile-dysfunction drug companies and
they've all done well now I'm investing
in this are you with me here's my check
I don't need to know anything else I
think I think Sean's gonna want to ask
you questions on angel investing and I
want to ask them and I want to hear his
answer or your answers to those
questions but before we get to that what
about selling I mean so you've sold more
than a handful of businesses selling
companies is hard most people will never
sell one how are you how are you able to
sell so many you think but you know that
that's a that's a great question because
and let me ask you saying I don't know
if we've talked about this have you ever
sold a company I had a small like
hundreds of thousands of dollars sale
for this company the hustle we had term
sheets and I walked away at the last
minute I've had two or three term sheets
and I've walked away from them and I've
never closed the deal yes
so and I bought I've also helped by
companies - yeah so it's a similar it's
similar skills on both sides of but
maybe slightly different but people
don't realize selling a company is very
difficult like it's there's three skills
there's starting a company
there's building it and they're selling
it and Sean
his company - to twitch yeah okay
congratulations for you yeah and you so
you know what I'm talking about like
you'll you'll your company's up for sale
and everybody's and you meet a bunch of
people I don't know if you met a bunch
of people but like I would meet a bunch
of people each time and you kind of
there's this courtship and you kind of
fall in love with each other I just like
in a courtship and then there's and then
there's suddenly you move into a
different period where lawyers take over
and you're waiting it's a waiting period
and it's a due diligence period and it's
a very painful period because before you
were in this like massive selling and
dating mood but now you're like living
together and you're getting to know each
other and you know you don't want her to
figure this out too fast and you know
before she really falls in love and you
know and all that dopamine you get when
you first meet has gone away and it's by
the way that's when I started this
podcast was during the due diligence
period because I got so itchy because I
was waiting and I was like oh my god I'm
gonna jeopardize this deal either
because I'm gonna push too hard and just
because I'm impatient or I'm gonna go
start another business which is the
worst thing I can do while trying to
sell this one sounds like I need to have
something and so that's why I started
the podcast was during that due
diligence period yeah that's smart
because I would just do nothing but wait
and it's it's it's a painful process and
the way you sell is first off you have
to and this is not you have to be
sincere the whole way through you have
to have a vision that matches their
vision very strongly and it has to
explain why you would well if this your
business is so great why do you want to
sell it like there's that inherent
contradiction in selling a business and
I was always aware that I would you know
in every business I've sold that I would
be better off with a better capitalized
partner and now maybe I would limit my
upside but you know the first time you
saw a company for millions and then the
second time if you're broke the second
time you still owe me four millions and
then the third time it's okay to not
sell for billions because you want to
get that initial chunk but you also have
to say look together here's how it's one
plus one equals three and you have to be
really persuasive on on why one plus
one equals three even for you personally
like you have to be able to express that
this vision is gonna benefit you
personally if you partner with this
other company and and and and it has to
really make sense and then and then of
course you have to survive this waiting
period you have to survive the initial
period where they're still checking you
out but now you're together and you have
to integrate and get along and you have
to keep all your employees because
usually there's some back-end earn out
or something like that like that every
you have to understand deal structure so
you're not ripped off it's very easy to
be ripped off by lawyers in a deal and
people don't realize that and you have
to be you have to have some skills at
negotiation which negotiating is one of
those things that 9 out of 10 people
think that they're above average which
is impossible like you have to be four
out of ten only could be above the
median and only one out of ten is really
good enough to to sell a company
improperly and so I had to learn the
hard way how to negotiate and like when
they come to you and they say well how
much do you want for your company that's
a very hard question to answer because
you don't want to sound greedy and you
don't want to sound desperate and you
don't want to sound and you don't want
to underprice yourself so there's all
sorts of negotiating techniques that you
have to use to help them answer that
question in a way that works for both
sides not just do you value your
companies on a multiple of your profit
or revenue or was it if we you use our
stuff with your audience or your current
products it will create this much value
so that also is a really great question
because this there's three ways to value
a company right the one is a standard
industry multiple on your earnings and
cut it in half by the way because no
one's gonna pay the maximum you cut it
in half so they everybody wants to get a
deal so like if if you have a profitable
company and it's an industry that trades
on the stock market for 20 times
earnings then your company is probably
your last year's profits times 10 the
20/2
that's just a basic formula or you could
do what you just said which is hey and I
learned this for my second company I
didn't limit for my for my first company
was profitable unlike every other
internet company and so we sold for
about 10 times earnings which was was a
mistake on the second company was like
I've did value
like how you said which is if if you if
we put ads all over here and you're
driving this amount of traffic and we
monetize those ads and then you cut that
in half this is what we're worth and the
second company I sold on the basis of
that the challenge there is with the
other company you work out this formula
for how you're gonna value your company
based on their them helping you build
your earnings and the challenges then
you fill in all the variables they know
the variables better than you so you
have to make sure when you're
negotiating the formula that and you
agree on the formula that you understand
the variables enough so that it works
out to what you want I didn't do that
part properly on my second negotiation
and then the third way to value things
is you look at other companies acquired
in the space they sold for this we're
bigger so we should be this now that's
kind of a BS way to value a company but
that is how people value companies often
particularly in the in the tech sector
like giffy I don't know what the how
they value themselves but certainly
wasn't off of earnings I don't think
they had 20 million dollars in earnings
my guess is they were losing money so so
they probably valued off of something
some kind of comparable to deal in in
the internet yeah cuz and then tenor
solo tenor which was good if he's
competitor just sold to Google a year
before for a little less than that who
was their competitor a company called
tenor T enor they were and it just says
society is it true that gippy was the
second largest search engine in the
world that's what they're saying
yeah they don't they know they love this
I thought YouTube was yep
so YouTube is number two and three
Amazon for right like so yeah depends
what you call a search engine well I did
in New York and it is huge it was just
there was nobody make money off of it
really yeah I had that issue I was I was
a seed investor and on the board of
bitly so bitly had about 5% of the
internet's traffic every day running
through it and for the life of us we
just could not figure out how to
monetize it like it was impossible and
they did exit the private equity firm I
bought it but it was like
two or three acts which is not really
what you're looking for an angel
investment and so James when you lose
your you lose all your money the first
time you call back you make money again
doing something else you lose it again
I mean obvious question at some point
were you like okay rainy day fund two
million bucks is going into this account
and hey I lost the I lost the keys just
so you know just to stash some money
away
what surely your life was like come on
man how did you get away with not just
saving something I got divorced and I
lost the second house that I bought and
no I kind of finally I think it was the
third time or the fourth time I finally
looked back and I said what was I always
doing right on the way up and what was I
doing wrong on the way down and there
were things in common which is just that
I kind of I kind of would just give up
after I made a lot of money I would kind
of say whew I did my job as a human now
I can just let my health go away my
relationships I don't care about anymore
I don't need to be creative anymore you
know I don't need to have any kind of
sense of spirituality and I was just
whatever and I just would lose all sense
of things and and not take care of
myself and not just physically but like
emotionally and creatively and so I just
made it a very concentrated effort it
sounds sort of cliche and almost
self-help helped me a little bit but I
really would make a concerted effort to
keep myself physically healthy to have
only good people in my life and quickly
eliminate any toxic people I guess like
the speed of light no second chances and
creatively I just started writing down
every single day ten ideas a day like
and it could be business ideas it could
be writing ideas it could be dumb ideas
it could be ideas for TV shows it could
be ideas for how Google could be a
better search engine and then I would
arrogantly send them to Google but the
whole idea was not to have good ideas
but to just practice this creativity
muscle or else it would atrophy and
literally like I'm not I'm not trying to
sell anything here like literally within
months of
writing ten ideas a day down it felt as
if my whole brain was rewired and I
would just I would bounce back so
quickly with ideas is just non-stop and
then the aspect of sometimes I would
write ideas for other companies and I
would send them these ideas if I thought
they were pretty good and you know I
would always get new opportunities
because of that like I would visit
Facebook Amazon LinkedIn Google Cora
Airbnb and just just this one process of
writing ten ideas a day down for the
past twelve years has been such an
incredible thing for me I can't even
praise it enough so the other day just
for fun a friend of mine recently took a
job at Disney plus and he was just like
because of this lockdown we're not
getting any good ideas pitched to us so
I'm like well what are you looking for
and he said we're looking specifically
for unscripted ideas that would cater to
nine year olds so I wrote my list of 10
ideas the next day and I sent it to him
he forwarded it to that I don't know how
like he forwarded to the head of reality
programming at Disney and right after
this I'm meeting they got excited and
right after this I'm meeting uh with
Disney to go over the ideas what was
there um as someone who's gone up and
down and up and down
can you explain what your happiness
levels went like what the range was from
like let's say zero dollars to ten
thousand dollars to a hundred to like 1
million to 15 million like what was the
difference in hat your happiness and
fulfillment things like that oh my god
so and really we're just talking about
the first time because then there's
different where it's different each time
but um I had zero dollars in the bank
and I was living in a studio in Astoria
Queens which is you know was not in the
night early nineties was not a nice part
of Queens before that I had a roommate
and in a apartment smaller than the room
you're seeing me in and I was paying
$300 a month he's working at HBO for
40,000 a year I was I had a suit in a
garbage bag that I would pull out every
day and put on the same suit seven days
in a row and walk over to HBO
and then we did the very first site I
did was this diamond dealer and he gave
me seventeen thousand five hundred
dollars in cash this is 1994 and I had I
had never had seen any money like this
before seventeen thousand five like he
almost was like I couldn't believe this
was actually happening and I walked over
to the Chelsea Hotel on 23rd Street was
like this sort of famous artsy hotel but
also really rundown and I gave the owner
like the whole bag was a paper bag of
seventeen thousand five hundred dollars
and said could I live here for a year
and he said are you a drug dealer and I
said no I work at HBO and he let me live
there and I was just so happy like oh
I'm living in Manhattan now and in this
cool hotel and I felt like part of
something I felt like part of a scene I
felt magical and that was an amazing
moment and then when I sold that first
business I felt good but it was weird
because it was so much pain closing that
deal like I was so stressed out in the
months prior to that and I got burnt out
and that's when I started playing poker
every single night just to kind of
escape burnout so I don't know if I was
happy or just more escapist then and
then when I started losing and every
time I lost every single time I've lost
everything I was suicidal and in part
for practical reasons I thought maybe my
my kids could live off my life insurance
and particular that first time there
were babies so I figured they wouldn't
remember me but they'll definitely
remember the life insurance so
fortunately I I couldn't figure out how
to do it in such a way as to not hurt
myself and I never did it and you know I
was very depressed though for long
periods of time but each time the period
of depression would get faster and
faster and you know I think one of the
most probably important things I've been
learning you know I used to think
learning is like you know in school it's
like learn math and then as you get a
little bit older you're like oh maybe I
should learn some skills like sales or
programming or whatever and now I'm like
oh all that the only skill that
matters is sort of managing my own
psychology my own emotions and so I
started to you know figure out what
works for me
right like cool if I exercise here's how
I feel if I you know eat this if I make
this decision if I listen to this song
whatever I started to find different
little ways to manage my own psychology
do you have a sort of any things that
you've worked on or you figured out that
help you either you know boost up
gratitude or like you know get out of
that Yap depression funk what works for
you or do you are you conscious about
that yeah very much so and that was part
of this realization that every single
day and I even it's I call it my
specific daily practice and it's it
could be different for each person but I
always have to ask what am i doing to
eat move sleep so that's physical health
I always try to stay healthy
like I don't I'm not an athlete I'm not
a you know not used to working out or I
mean I'm 52 years old I've got a stay as
healthy as possible and so eat everyday
I have to make sure I'm eating well
sleeping eight hours and and moving and
now with this pandemic lockdown is I
have to go outside and make sure I have
some outside time and then emotional
health
just what how much are the people around
me toxic or not and that is the key to
emotional health nothing else and then
creative health am i writing ten ideas a
day down because creativity not only is
it rewiring your brain to be more
creative you know or that muscle
atrophies but it also triggers a lot of
dopamine when you're creative and it
just if I do it in the morning to work
on my ten ideas a day list I've got this
surge of dopamine that carries me at
least till like 1:00 or 2:00 in the
afternoon and then spiritual health is
just am I trying to control things I
can't control so that's a very important
part of spiritual health so you see
people on Twitter all day long oh man
they should we need to open up this
economy right now or we need to lock
down all the people who open up like on
both sides they're trying to control
things they can't control and they're
all day long they're 24 hours a day on
Twitter and even during this pandemic I
felt like I was getting a little into
that and then I pulled myself back and
realized it wasn't I can't control this
so it wasn't healthy for me and so
always
avoiding trying to control things you
can't control is very important and that
really just those four things physical
emotional creative spiritual just those
four things if I attend to them every
day I keep at a very high state and even
when I'm even when I lose money now or
go up and money i keeps me very you know
contentment and well-being are much more
important than happiness happiness is
very as the cliche goes is very fleeting
but well-being you build a real
foundation of well-being and that and
that sticks with you
so what's your business now James that
you're like which like your job now uh
well I do I do lots of things so I mean
I I write every day and I just finished
a book that will be published by
HarperCollins in a year I do a podcast I
am still involved in my newsletter
business which I sold I'm I'm a private
investor in about two dozen private
companies so I'm but I'm remember I'm
not active in those because they don't I
don't want them to want my advice so
it's very very passive but I have to
make sure I'm enough in the deal flow
that each year I can still put a little
bit of money to work because you never
know which year you'll find the next
uber or whatever and and a lot of my
time the past five years until this
lockdown has been on stand-up comedy
which makes you know which makes minimal
at best so then you did did your nut for
your angel money that came from like
your initial sale really really now most
the way I make a living and the way I
built up is just from private investing
because pretty much every company I've
sold I ended up losing all or most of
the money but private investing is now
the way I've been able to make a living
most of all so on the angel front so
what percent of your money do you have
your net worth do you put into angel
deals which is a risky illiquid thing
I'm very much now and this is this was
the key point that made a big difference
for me investing is that risk is the
most important part of investing whether
you're investing money or you're
investing time Ritt risk has to be
managed and
about first and foremost and the way I
remove risk is two ways one is as I
mentioned I always invest with people
who are smarter than me because I let
that outsource some of the risk
management to people who are
professionals at it and the other way I
manage risk is position size so I never
invest more than 1 to 2 percent of my
net worth is the maximum I will ever
invest in any company right now I'll let
the I'll let the investment grow to much
more than that it's sort of like what
Warren Buffett says if you've got
Michael Jordan on your team you don't
trade I'm just because he got better so
I like it when good private companies
don't exit because that means they're
growing still at like 50 to 200 percent
a year and as long as they're doing that
I don't want them to exit and what was
your biggest angel or private company
you win so far which company yeah it's
it's it's hard to say because a lot of
my investments are doing really well but
there's still private like I have deals
I invested in in 2009 which are still
doubling every year but they they're
still private but that buddy media won
you know four million to seven hundred
million was pretty good ticket fly was
another one that invested in which I was
in the seed round of that and it sold
for 450 million I invested in another
one which is public now it's a law
enforcement company they have a gun that
if they we I was sort of a co-founder of
this it started in the living room I was
staying at and there was a hashtag black
lives matter was the trending hashtag
and so we tried to solve that problem
basically so we found an inventor who
made a gun that fires a Kevlar cable at
you at the speed of sound and it wraps
around you and the more you try to
struggle to get out of it it squeezes
tighter and so like like a Batman I was
gonna say straight out of Batman yeah
and even the one of the founders of
taser is the president of the company
now he became the president company
about a year ago and we went public it's
it's a really great company it's still
in growth mode but they're starting to
to sell quite a bit and that's been I'm
not exited actually I'm
I own the shares of the public company
I'm not planning on exit
hopefully ever because it's it's what's
up no competition the comings called rap
technology so I'm not trying to push the
stock or anything so I don't want to
even mention that right the stock stock
symbol but it's it's it's just such a
great thing to invest in and be a part
of the founding of something that's
literally saves lives every single day
so when you can you have the journal
with you that you write your 10 ideas
can we like what what do you what's
interesting to you right now James a lot
of times it's in my email oh there's my
iPad I do it all in waders Pat's or I do
it in my email so if I'm out in a cafe I
do it in a waiters pad and if I do it at
a sitting at my computer I'll do it in
my email well as an angel investor and I
don't know if you're ever gonna start
another company again maybe you are
maybe you aren't but as someone who's
always scheming what what do you have
your eye on now yeah I've no problem
even saying what I'm scheming at because
so I haven't considered starting a new
company in a very long time
but I have been considering it now and
one of the ideas is I feel it's a shame
that content is not monetized unless
you're like but in the top 1/10 of 1% of
content creators so you have to be like
you know Logan Paul to monetize your
YouTube channel and the other twenty
billion people on YouTube even if they
have one video that goes viral they
can't monetize it so or like even if you
have a if you have a tweet that 20
million people see but you have only 300
followers
you can't monetize it so I've been
figuring out a way to use these
ecosystems to allow people to monetize
content so that's one idea I'm working
on actually physically working on it and
another one involves making a derivative
of a board game that I like but in
general I don't I don't come up with
business ideas I come up with like like
I said the other day I had this
challenge like of oh I'm gonna challenge
myself to come up with TV show ideas
that nine year olds would like and I did
that and I sent it off and usually I
don't send it off or sometimes the ideas
are ideas for books I could write or if
I have an idea for a book I could write
like the next idea all right
of chapter titles and again most of the
ideas are supposed to be bad because you
can't come up with 3650 good ideas a
year and it'd be foolish to think so
so I'm just trying to come up with bad
ideas what I'm trying to make my brain
sweat so for instance one idea list that
it's particularly hard is and this is
the one I wrote this morning is 10 good
positive things that have happened to me
personally because of this lockdown
those aren't actionable ideas but it was
actually hard to come up with 10 like 1
through 7 is always usually pretty easy
by 8 9 10 is usually makes my I feel
like my brain sweating and but yeah but
a lot of times we'll come up with
business ideas or I'll start to say to
myself what industries are gonna be
attractive after this that are
unexpected so you can't say the obvious
ones like obviously you know video
communications technology is going to be
a attractive businesses emphasis instead
I would think what are the 10 ways I can
improve unzoom which was is the most
popular one right now so that will be
how I exercise the idea muscle around
zoom and for your content idea is there
a comp out there like is there somewhere
something out there that you'd like man
this like little behavior that some
people are doing I think that if we just
blew this up or systemize this this
could actually have legs yeah so sort of
so I'll do something what I'll call what
I call idea sex so I'll take ideas from
two completely different industries and
again I've been a professional in many
different industries again fortunately
or unfortunately and I'll combine ideas
to see if after I do sex there's a
little idea baby that could work in what
I'm doing so for instance if I go to a
restaurant and have a pretty good meal
that meal could get monetized and if the
waiter or waitress treats me nice they
might get they they have better chances
of monetizing their behavior than
otherwise
so there's lots to learn from how
monetization works in the bottom third
of the economy in other industries so a
waiter is the
third of the is in the bottom third of
people who work in restaurants or
involved in the restaurant industry so
how do they monetize themselves and
there's a lot there's a lot of
industries where you can say hey the
bottom third of this sector or this
space or this country they don't make
any money but but they could maybe and
you could look at that as examples of
you know how do i how do i lighten up
this third by allowing them to collect
money this is that's gonna be always a
huge industry square is a great example
square took the mom-and-pop store that
couldn't accept credit cards because no
bank would trust them and square enable
them to accept credit cards so squares
the only company in the world that does
that and they became I don't know a
twelve billion dollar company because
they were able to monetize the bottom
third of you know mom-and-pop retail
stores and so that's one model for
creating a billion dollar company and
then I might use idea sex to generate
the ideas like oh how does every other
industry monetize their bottom third
let's apply it to YouTube and see what
happens you know and then I'll look at
competitors like okay there's patreon
but you have to patreon has various
hurdles you you have to already know
you're gonna be a good content creator
and you have to come up with awards and
you have to interact and create content
specifically for patreon and so-and-so
patreon has problems so I try to look at
hey I think yeah like if you're a
content creator patreon could be a great
way to make money but it's it I find a
lot of content creators once they have a
big audience
I'm patreon to be more annoying than
helpful but advertising also is annoying
so you know finding advertisers yourself
and outsourcing all your advertising to
YouTube could also be annoying so you
know there's various problems in the
current ways people monetize I mean you
guys monetize a newsletter subscriptions
another way but that puts a some
friction in front of your subscribers
and so you know I've done newsletters
I've done you know advertising supported
media like podcasts or websites and so
I'm familiar with all these types of
monetization and I don't know all these
things together help me make my idea
list what's your favorite wave ways for
monetizing content
for me right now I don't think I've ever
really monetized content the way I would
like to like subscription okay so but
let me ask you a question subscription
is the best way to monetize most content
but again you have to plan for that in
advance so you have to say I'm gonna
make a subscription and called a
subscription product called the hustle
with with new ideas and trends every
week you've made by migrate analysts and
people are willing to pay a dollar a
month or whatever ten dollars or
whatever it is and subscription is a
great way to monetize because you're not
always chasing advertisers it's this
annuity that comes in and helps you even
survive in a recessionary environment or
like right now so I love I think
subscription is a whether it's an online
newsletter or an online course or a
subscription community like you know
let's say the trends Facebook community
I think subscriptions my favorite way to
monetize but it doesn't solve the
problem of monetizing when you're not
already in the top one third of content
like like you guys are in the top 1/10
of 1% of content you're going to
monetize and do very well no matter what
model you choose whereas the someone who
rakes a newsletter about I don't know
you know some obscure kind of Taekwondo
or whatever they're not gonna be able to
monetize a newsletter necessarily where
someone who's gonna monetize how to mow
the lawn better is not gonna be able to
monetize but might have one piece of
content that really stands out and if
you were you know I think you're pretty
much one of the top 1% or better of
people at building new businesses or
audiences right I think you've done an
amazing job of building up audiences
that will follow you through one medium
podcasting blogging email whatever you
want let's say you're 21 years old again
today you know everything you know now
but nobody knows your name how would you
go about building an audience today yeah
today I will first off let's assume I
have something to say you have to have
something you have to have a unique
perspective and again I'll I'll take
I'll take the this podcast as an example
it's my first million it's the name of
this podcast right yep so
there are other podcasts about there's
there's a podcast the eventual
millionaire which talks to millionaires
about it but most of these other
podcasts unlike you most of them are
started by people who haven't yet sold
their first business or haven't made
that first million so their unique thing
is they're approaching people almost as
if they're asking for advice how can I
do it you did it how can I do it so
that's a different your perspective is
you've done it so you're able to more in
a different type of nuance drill down on
that and you have something unique to
bring out of people and say to people
and so on and and and Sam for you you've
spent so much time studying trends and
side hustles and the gig economy the
hustle is like the best email newsletter
out there because it's your you're the
voice of it is so unique it's it's the
go-to particularly during this lockdown
it's it's amazing people ask me hey what
are some side gigs we could do from home
the first thing I always say is check
out the hustle and you'll get a ton of
ideas even on our podcasts and it was
just like spinning out ideas that I've
run with it's completely stolen from you
so that's the other thing about having
good ideas they could steal them from
people but you know I think you have to
something you have to have something
unique to say so at the age of 22 you
have to question well do I really have
something unique to say and often when I
write something I don't hit publish
unless I'm afraid of what people will
think about me after I hit publish
because otherwise that I'm probably not
saying something new or different or you
know there has to be I have to challenge
myself in some way to create unique
content but give it let's assume you
have something unique to say or some
expertise you built up by the age of 22
I would go on Quora and just answer
every question I could I would
participate on LinkedIn groups again
answering every question I could I would
go on groups like the trends group or
other Facebook groups and you know a lot
of people ask questions I would go on
podcasters paradise which is a
subscription community about podcasting
I would a lot of people say hey what you
know how do you get good guests or how
do you what kind of microphone should I
use I would answer every question I
could and establish expertise and then I
would again I'm thinking if I'm 22
I'm not thinking this way now and then
once I had some expertise
I would sprint out so now have you just
you just saw me everywhere you looked
you saw me Quora LinkedIn Facebook
there's James again answering questions
now I'll start going on sites where
there's a little bit higher barrier to
create content so like a Forbes calm or
Inc calm or TechCrunch or whatever and
and this is what I did do and I started
would start writing or Yahoo Finance I
start writing articles for them so now
people see me in a more of a position of
authority so it's not just I have like a
number of sort of number of followers on
either Korra or Twitter or LinkedIn or
whatever it's like oh I just saw James
encore and now I see him on cnn.com
what's he doing there and so so I
establish some authority then you got to
create an email newsletter and it's free
99% of your content has to be free so I
would create an email newsletter and
always just at the end of my articles I
would say hey you want to hear more from
me I have an email newsletter sign up
now and I'll give you my book the top 20
hustles for 20 20 and just for free and
you know just and then I would just
start putting all my articles on my free
email and then I'd start at some point
my level of expertise should be big
enough that I can start a for pay
subscription newsletter like whether
it's about trends or stocks or some
physical activity or and this is the
exact thing you did I mean I think that
from an outside perspective I mean it
looks like your newsletter business
makes tens of millions in subscription
revenue yeah so so I did do that and
again it wasn't the first business I
started that would have been a good
first business if the question was if I
was 22 what would I do that is how I did
do that that latest business that I sold
and and it worked that model works and I
encourage other people sorry online
course like a friend of mine has an
online course that she started this
person is the most introverted shy
person I know and she started a course
on how to be noticed by the media how to
become a media expert and she priced it
at $700 she said she opens it up for
like three days every year sells another
thousand and makes seven hundred
thousand a year
and you know lives in a cheap country
she moved there just to keep expenses
down and you know this is a and it's
just a course so it's not an ongoing
newsletter I think an online course is
better actually than newsletters and I
think affiliate deals are better than
also creating an online newsletter so so
if I were to redo my business I would do
it over slightly but you know that
that's what I would do if I was starting
completely from scratch I think I've
seen that methodology work over and over
again and it is the advice I give people
because content creation is is king like
that is always there's a demand how many
times you've been asked this during this
lockdown man what what show should i
watch I feel like I've watched
everything content people always want
more content all the big content
creators spend hundreds of billions on
content just on sitcoms this year so
there's so much demand for content and
you can provide value like if you really
again ninety-nine percent of your
content will still be free that's key
but you could provide extra value that
it's worth paying for like for instance
I forget if I get I think I get the
hustle for free right like that's funny
trends is not trends is not but but the
hustle you convinced me I love the
hustle and that's where most of your
content is yeah but it's it's the
quality and the voice in the hustle that
convinced me okay I need to get trends
and I'm happy to always pay for it and
it's or it mean it's just gone but
we got yeah but there's value like if
you don't provide value then people are
gonna realize pretty quickly that you're
useless like you always have to provide
value and have something and have a
unique perspective yeah I think that is
the key in the hardest part is having
the unique perspective everything after
that is sort of the textbook you know
you run the PlayBook after that of how
do I did it out there for free how do I
collect you know over customer
relationship and then how do i monetize
for the most hardcore but the only
perspective is hard how do you shape
that I'll give you another example like
do you guys play fantasy sports at all
yeah okay so I do not play fantasy
sports I knew I don't even know the
rules of football but Matt Barry who's
the fantasy sports anchor at ESPN and he
also hosts this TV show the fantasy
showed ESPN that
guy was a Hollywood screenwriter he was
writing movies and TV shows and he hated
his life and he quit that it's making a
ton of money he quit that I started
writing blog he just loves sports and
fantasy sports
he started blogging about that for a
hundred dollars a blog post just kind of
broke after all this and quitting
Hollywood moved away and a hundred
dollars of blog post was the most he can
get but because he had this writing
skill from his Hollywood Times uh he had
a quickly got a huge audience in fantasy
sports then he built a for pay
subscription site and you know after
producing Moses condom for free ESPN
bought it and he kept moving up the
ranks there and boom he's he's done so
much better doing what he loves at
fantasy sports and monetizing in almost
the same way I just described and he's
so much happier than when he was writing
movies which is a lot of people consider
the dream job I love it we should we
should wrap up in a second James this
was awesome I got to admit you were way
more legit than I expected it you know I
thought you were what why did you expect
me not to be legit okay I've already
already called them out on this which
last time he called himself out he goes
so when his company was acquired Sean
James like dude my contents legit I'm
legit I do it all but the acquiring
company admittedly is incredibly
aggressive with the advertising and
sometimes that uh kinda makes me appear
as though I'm one thing when I'm not
yeah and and and and by the way it's a
very interesting topic how aggressive
you should be with your advertising and
they're so aligned to Putin who's this
French philosopher he is this theory
that even the good guys need to use
Machiavellian tactics they need to use
that because otherwise if I just said
hey guys I have a unique perspective on
Bitcoin please listen to me
there was so much aggressive advertising
out there they would have drowned me out
and I would have not succeeded in my
mission which was to inform people what
I thought was a correct view of Bitcoin
and then what would have been the point
right so sometimes and but but it did
cost me though like doing because my ads
were so good we dominated I mean that
was the reason Facebook Google and every
shut down crypto ads is because of my
ads yeah that was definitely a little
piece of it but what I actually meant
was most of the time when a guest comes
on I think to myself well there's a
really successful person but man they're
there you know they don't tell great
story you know they they do not bring
you know sort of energy stories and also
you know some unique insights that the
audit that you know I'm imagining I'm a
listener right like during this
interview you talked for the most of us
I was actually you know listener number
one for this podcast episode and I would
have liked this one and so I I can't
always say that that's the case with all
of our guests but you brought that
that's all I really meant what you're
legit which is huh you know I've raised
the bar for the podcast which is great
excellent thank you so much so James
this was awesome if people want to say
hi to you is Twitter your go-to method
no I'm James Altucher on tick-tock my
absolute best content tick-tock 50-year
old dude perspective oh yeah I'm not
dancing I did do one one time I danced
and someone said someone literally said
commented dude this is not why we found
out this I took that one down and I
haven't danced since although if if push
came to shove and I was drunk I when I
was 12 years old I was a
semi-professional breakdancer big boy
breakdancer that's an ass man we
appreciate you coming I I'm looking
forward to joining you again and you
coming back to us and developing a
friendship that's awesome excellent yeah
and and Shawn yeah definitely let's have
you on the podcast as well so all cool
let's exchange emails and we'll figure
it all out
sounds good thank you all right all
right you guys thanks a lot talk to you
soon bye
[Music]